[Musique]
1828 avec l'esclavage l'angagisme a été
l'autre forme d'exploitation humaine
utilisé sur l'île de Laarne un engagé
est une personne libre et recruté comme
travailleur pour un contrat le 3 à 5
ans au début du peuplement la Compagnie
des Indes a tenté de faire venir des
engagés européens mais ce fut un échec
car les conditions de vie étaient bien
trop difficiles pour eux
elle a alors eu recours à l'esclavage
mais après l'abolition de la traite par
les vainqueurs de Napoléon les maîtres
comprennent qu'il faut prévoir d'autres
sources d'approvisionnement pour les
ouvriers dont ils ont besoin en 1828
soit 20 ans avant l'abolition un essai
est fait avec les 15 premiers engagés du
sucre depuis l'Inde britannique dès 1830
ils sont plus de 3000 à débarquer après
le 20 décembre 1848 les planteurs
accélèrent cette migration de
travailleurs fuyant la misère
majoritairement composé d'hommes venant
d'Afrique de Chine et
d'Inde en 1860 la France signe un traité
avec l'Angleterre pour faire venir en
masse des angagés Indiens l'accord prend
fin le 11 novembre
1882 les engagés indiens ont apporté
leur religion qu'il pouvaient pratiquer
librement mais aussi leurs habitudes
alimentaires qui ont fait du riz et des
caris des repères de notreident
Collectiv 1828 arrivée des premiers
engagés
[Musique]
indiens